what's up brother well my
i posted a tick tock and it did more
views than my
last three videos combined
looks like i'm a tick-tock it looks like
we all
are dude looks like we're all
tick-tocking
i love that i love when people say when
people i see people on
interviews and they're like uh you know
like tick-tockers and people are like
what are the benefits of tick-tock and
they're like
you can just grow so fast
you're just it's just such so easy to
grow you know
it's like um and another example is
charlie demilio got 100 million
followers in like a year
yeah and it took pewdiepie 10 years yeah
for
longer than that take it to 100 million
subscribers yeah
and it's just like i don't know i it's
something irks me about using
growth as a catch-all term for real
human beings
pressing follow in an app and like
dedicating themselves to like watching
you you know what i'm saying
yeah it's just dude i can't just grow
it's so easy to grow man it's so easy to
just like
you know uh corral these [ __ ] sheep
to to view what i
do you know
it's also the weirdest place to brag
about growth because it's
the least least amount of effort yeah
hell yeah i know like you're following
you could follow
5 000 on tick who gives a [ __ ] yeah who
gives
i think that's what they mean too it's
like so easy to grow meaning
i don't have to do [ __ ] and people and i
get money
yeah that's uh that you know that part i
don't really understand um you know i'm
just
i'm just coming to grips with the fact
that you know
it's just so easy to grow on there and i
had no clue
that this late this this was sitting
right there the whole time
yeah sorry tell me about your growth
tell me about the the views
what was the video well first of all
that
the tick tock i watched it again and
kind of chuckled to myself because i'm
like man
this comes across a lot more bitter than
i had intended i was just trying to make
a you know a little funny
everyone's always making fun of my bald
head whatever
and so i just i figure out the green
screen thing and i'm like let me just
make a little joke about this
and i woke up this morning and two
million
views
what i know i hate it i hate how much i
respond to that
to that feeling too when you post a tick
tock and you wake up and you
see that number and you're like [ __ ]
yeah i it wasn't
i don't i didn't even have that yet i
just was looking at it
feeling i just more questioning you
didn't have a little part of your brain
that was like
what's the next no it's definitely dope
like i looked at it and i was like that
number is awesome but then it just made
me feel
stupid about everything i said oh why do
i why do we even try to
be funny we should why try anything
exactly it's so much easier to grow on
tick tock just do this
yeah just do this no that's that's a bad
attitude but
yeah you know it was it was a shock
for sure i haven't even seen it is there
music can we pull it up yeah you could
play it there's no music
okay okay you know let's do it no
pressure to laugh
if it doesn't make you laugh it's okay
it won't hurt my feet no i'm gonna laugh
my little nads off dude
let me just real quick here okay oh okay
two guys on the pc i see it okay hold on
let me screen share why does this
it's why is this so hard share screen
and
there we go okay wait i gotta do audio
hold on
this is so weird man this ui is just
oh okay there we go the ui just makes it
so easy to grow
that's so easy to grow yeah exactly
all right
[ __ ] y'all man
[Laughter]
shout out to symbol love but the rest of
you is that all you do on this app
i don't come on this app and when i do
it's just you look like this bald person
you know i've learned this quarantine
you guys only know four bald people and
one of them isn't even bald
you only know obama spooky from
on my block or whatever uh this dude and
dog face
that's it that's that's the only rules
you have you look like
that [ __ ] sucks get a new roast
nice roasting the roast
i like it i don't know whoops whatever
man still going here we go there we go
um more more views than sophia in 24
hours
what you want to shout that music video
we did all that stupid work for what
i feel like it's fake man i feel like
all those stats are fake somehow they're
fake
it it's all fake or or tick-tock really
is that poppin
or there are there really are that many
people
going through their feed on tick tock
every second of every day
i couldn't i could see that only i could
actually see it being real now
because we're all locked inside the
house yo speaking of pandemic
how do we never joke about pfizer making
viagra
and the vaccine why what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean dude
they're gonna get some tubes crossed in
the lab and
that was yeah that was it was ripe right
we missed that people are gonna have no
problem growing yeah
i'm sure everyone else has hit the bits
and we just didn't do any
why can you imagine if that [ __ ] got
crossed and
you wonder if you're a vaccine and you
just came out hard as nails
like why are people complaining about
getting this it's awesome i've been hard
for seven
years i've had a boner like this since i
was 12.
it's instant it starts like as it's
going down the syringe your dick is like
it's like matching the pace of the
syringe so like
what's happening what is happening
i don't know man that [ __ ] killed me
that though those people it's totally
normal
everyone
she and the the lady at cvs injects you
she's like looking down in your pants
for a second she looks away what
oh no usually there's a well no i feel
it
no it's there oh i'm sorry i just
uh it didn't appear sorry no no i'm
not seeing much of a tent here no i'm
pitched i'm i'm definitely pitched
this is more of a birdhouse no i'm up
i'm up i'm up that's not a burden that's
the whole thing that's the whole up well
it's because i'm wearing subie jeans
they're a little bit so it doesn't
exactly let me
hold on let me know just to be clear you
are fully torqued right now let me push
my thighs together hold on
okay yeah that's a little bit better see
now now there's more of a doll house
not yeah no no no hold on hold on hold
on hold on
what we're looking for to make sure the
vaccine is you know registering
correctly is a full-on tent
someone behind can you hurry up hold on
just let me move my fendi belt
it's getting in the way the buckle is is
so heavy it you know it's it's an
expensive one so it's real heavy it
just weighs on my dick and balls and so
it holds them down sometimes my boner
doesn't
it's dragged it's dragging my pitch down
yeah exactly yeah yeah
imagine building a tent but one side of
his weight in platinum it just it
wouldn't work so just hold on one second
is there a let me move my fendi belt
hold on let me move the other fendi belt
hold on yeah still yeah not
not seeing the height
just not getting the vertical on this
that we would like to see
you know what it is it's probably the
third fendi belt yeah sorry
for gucci belts on my waist bro
the people on the board of pfizer are
going to sleep
healthy and horny you know
you know what i mean like they just they
have
one of the most needed things in
medicine right now
about to roll out and they got the magic
blue pill
yeah you know they hid that vaccine like
six months ago and
popped a blue pill and just went to town
we're like we're rich
yeah we are gonna make millions and
millions and millions honey
[Laughter]
big pharma big pharma no more people are
gonna love us they're gonna worship us
you know that's the you think that's a
big pharma execs party they don't even
they don't even do drugs like that are
mind altering they just try different
vaccines and stuff
yeah high level medicine yeah they go
into the lab
and it's like one of those m m stores
[Laughter]
every color every different color pill
is all in a different container that's
what it's like going to the cp
ecstasy factory yeah you ever done a
benzo and tums
let me tell you it doesn't sound we call
it tumzo's
it doesn't sound like anything well let
me tell you we call it bums it's called
a bum
god and god damn and if you're feeling
if you're feeling crazy you crush it up
you do a bum bum
you crush it up into a bum bum when your
buddies blow it up to your ass through a
straw i'm telling you
a bum bum
nothing you've ever experienced before
you can eat a full pizza
and feel happy it's insane and your
stomach is uninhibited
ah [ __ ]